the european union is reportedly
planning to sanction 10 individuals and
two companies
connected to the military regime in
myanmar according to news agency reuters
the sanctions could come into effect by
next week
the sanctions come amid a warning from
the u.n human rights chief
who said the situation in the country
could be spiraling
to a full-blown syria style conflict
more than 700 people have been killed
since the military
took power in a coup in february and
since then
its crackdown on pro-democracy
protesters has only grown
stronger these are the lengths myanmar's
military will go to
to crack down on dissenting voices
this video from social media shows the
moment a prominent protest leader is
deliberately
rammed off his motorbike
waymo nang was arrested by armed men
after trying to flee the incident
with friends saying they now fear for
his safety
security forces have used increasingly
violent tactics to quell the anti-coup
movement
the un says there are echoes of the
civil war in syria
there too we saw peaceful protests met
with unnecessary and clearly
disproportionate force
the state's brutal persistent repression
of its own people
led to some individuals taking up arms
followed by a downward
and rapidly expanding spiral of violence
all across the country
despite the risk to their lives
protesters have been trying to keep up
the pressure on the military regime
the spilled red paint symbolizes the
blood of those who've died
activists say at least 700 people have
been killed since protests began in
february
normally at the moment people in myanmar
would be celebrating tanjan
a buddhist new year holiday but not this
year
it's important for young people to rebel
against a dictator
we can't be happy now as long as we live
under this dictatorship our future is
lost
the protesters aren't giving up but
neither it seems
is the military
phil robertson from human rights watch
has been monitoring the situation in
myanmar
for the past couple of months he joins
me now from bangkok phil
have we entered a phase in myanmar where
the junta is comfortable with the status
quo
and relatively confident of keeping
power
well i'm not sure that they're confident
yet but they are certainly acting on a
presumption that the protesters on the
streets
are their enemy and they're using lethal
force against them
uh you know they're treating myanmar
cities like a battlefield and
they've used machine guns and grenades
and rpgs against protesters in places
like bago
where last week we saw more than 80
people killed in one morning
now what are you hearing from protesters
on the ground do they feel
the international community standing up
for them
they are disappointed by the
international community they want to see
more action
they appreciate all the statements that
have been made by various foreign
ministers around the world and by the
u.n security council and others
but they're calling for much more i i
think if they had their way
uh they would see an invocation by the
u.n security council of the
responsibility to protect
doctrine and some sort of deployment uh
by the international community into
myanmar but i don't think that's
realistic and i don't think that's
really
in anybody's plans uh you know whether
it be the us eu or elsewhere
so you know the people i think are
disappointed the international community
hasn't come in as almost like the
cavalry but
they're determined to continue
protesting uh they're angry
at the military and they are uh quite
clear that they do not want this
myanmar military in any sort of future
for myanmar
and while we are talking phil there are
also reports that the eu may further
sanction officials and companies
connected to the junta now these aren't
going to be the first sanctions from the
eu
but is this going to help change the
situation
in any way
well it's a substantive step forward the
european union has frankly been a bit
slow
in imposing uh targeted economic
sanctions
now we're hearing that they're going to
go after uh the two major
military-controlled business
conglomerates uh the union myanmar
economic holdings and uh the myanmar
economic corporation which is
what we have been asking them to do from
the very beginning
we have to go after the companies we
have to go after the cash flow
to the myanmar military junta just
targeting
top level myanmar military officials
it's important but it's not enough
speaking of the economic side of things
i mean myanmar's main trading partners
in the region are countries like china
india japan
thailand for example do you think these
countries are doing enough
to enable a return to democracy
quite clearly the frontline states are
not doing enough to
actually uh pressure the myanmar
military junta
to return to the barracks and to allow
for the democracy that they have
destroyed to
uh be reconstituted i i think that
unfortunately we're seeing uh go along
to get along sort of arrangement
from these frontline states like
thailand and india
and now there's hope that somehow there
will be some action
from the uh asean the association of
southeast asian nations
but we're not seeing that we're just
seeing a very divided
regional body here that's not really
prepared to go forward in unity to
pressure the government in myanmar we
leave it
there for the time being but thank you
so much for joining us phil robertson
from human rights watch
thank you now the military's
violent crackdown against protesters is
forcing many to seek shelter
with armed ethnic groups that have been
for years
fighting the army groups such as the
karen national liberation army based in
southeastern cayenne state
on the border with thailand
the ethnic karen like many other ethnic
groups in the country have been
four years fighting the military for
some form of self-government
they are now proving life savers for
those fleeing the military's crackdown
on democracy it may not look like
much but this rural forest camp has
become a sanctuary
for myanmar's terrified protesters
although we had been protesting
peacefully we had to run away because of
the violent crackdown
we knew that if we were to get arrested
the security forces would not let us
live
they would kill us
they arrived in the territory of one of
the country's key armed rebel groups
the karan national liberation army the
group controls large waves of land on
the border with thailand
and has been fighting the central
government for the last 70 years
life in the camp is spartan among its
new inhabitants are striking teachers
who say they had no choice but to flee
there
after the junta issued warrants for
their arrests
there is now trust between the civil
servants and the ethnic armed groups
they help us and they're kind we feel
safe being here
since they started siding with us we
told them ask us for anything that we
can do to help
we are ready to help this new
partnership has brought renewed
attention to the broad spectrum of
resistance that the junta now faces
and raised concerns that should they go
on the offensive
violence could spiral out of control
and there's reports now of members of
ethnic groups uniting with ousted
lawmakers and anti-q protesters
to form a national unity government in
the country
something we'll be tracking in the
coming weeks